good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster at what stage will
the uk's vaccine roll out enable a
return
to something like normal a senior public
health england official has warned sky
news
some restrictions may need to be in
place until all adults
have received a vaccination and with
questions over how long lockdown will
last
how is the economy faring and how long
will it take to recover
also this morning pip rules the waves
after 95 days at sea british sailor pip
hair becomes only the eighth woman
to complete the sole solo bondi globe
race she joins us later on
back to beethoven the conductor looking
to the past to compare his own life with
that
of the great composer it's friday the
12th of february
a senior public health england official
tells sky news
coronavirus restrictions could be
required until all adults have been
vaccinated
the hidden cost of covid sky news
reports on a surge in mental health
referrals
during the pandemic
as wales hits its vaccine target
attention turns to the whole uk
and plans for the next phase of the
rollout
and senior democrats rest their case
against donald trump
warning more violence like the capital
riots could follow
if he's not convicted what is
impeachable conduct
if not this i challenge you all to think
about it if you think this is not
impeachable
what is and it becomes milder into the
new week but until then it's still
looking generally cold with the risk of
further snow i'll have further details
for you
later in the programme
for breaking news now and in the last
few moments the office
for national statistics has published
gdp figures
for the fourth quarter of last year
let's uh speak now to our economics and
data editor
ed conway uh what can you tell us ed
well julian these numbers have literally
just come out so at the moment i just
have the
the overall figure which is a 1.1 uh
sorry one percent growth
uh in the final quarter of last year now
that's actually a little bit better
than expected uh bear in mind that a lot
of people thought because of that second
lockdown
in much of the country during that
period that you might have seen
a contraction which would in turn
potentially lead to a double-dip
recession well
that hasn't happened it's one percent
growth um
and when you look at the total year as a
whole
i think that we're talking about around
9.9 so around
10 uh of a fall in gdp
uh last year i'm gonna have to kind of
go back into the spreadsheets and work
out when the last time that was
uh as bad i think that might be uh
a little bit less bad than we saw uh in
the 1920s
um i mean a lot of people at the time
were talking about how this was going to
be the worst recession
since uh the 18th century the early
period of the 18th century in terms of
the the
total fall over 2020 well now we have
those preliminary numbers
it may not be quite as bad as that but
as i say uh the figures have just
dropped so we're going to have a look at
them over the course
of the next hour or so we'll also be
talking to the chancellor rashid sunak
about his reaction to those numbers
uh and indeed to the state of the
economy now because in a way i think the
issue with this
is what we're doing right now and
obviously he's in the process of
preparing for a budget
what we're doing right now is looking at
numbers that are quite historic they're
numbers that cover
uh the final three months of last year
and during that period obviously there
was this
uh lockdown in much of the country but
it wasn't as severe as the lockdown that
we're facing
uh around most of the uk at the moment
uh and so the
expectation is the quarter we're in at
the moment so the period we're in right
now i know i suppose the question is
whether he's going to do anything more
like that is he
are there going to be stimulus measures
like eat out to help out uh they're
going to get get the economy going again
uh perhaps you'd have thought he
wouldn't do that
again but as i was saying this course
we're in right now this period we're in
at the moment
almost every economist thinks that we're
going to see a contraction and
some people have talked about double dip
recessions and there is this arbitrary
it's pretty arbitrary
idea that a recession is only when you
have two successive quarters of
contraction well because last quarter
the one we're talking about now
because there was growth then you're not
going to have a technical recession
but for most people when they look at
the numbers what they will conclude is
we're in a period right now of
potential contraction that's not good
news uh we'll have more from the
chancellor on that later on and more
analysis giving you a sense of just how
bad last year was really in historical
perspective
okay ed we'll leave you to drill down
into those figures for the moment thank
you
well i'm joined now by the home office
minister victoria atkins good morning to
you
good morning uh first of all can we get
your reaction
to those figures that we've just had
there
well we knew that the pandemic was going
to have an impact
on the economy and that's why the
measures that we took last year to
protect jobs and to safeguard businesses
have been so important if those measures
haven't
happened then i suspect we'd have looked
at we'd be looking at far worse figures
today so
you know the we we will come out of this
pandemic and the economy
will recover we've just got to keep uh
sticking with
this lockdown and we've got to stick
with
the plan that the chancellor has for us
moving out
of this period uh and in the light of
that what can we expect with the
budget are we likely to see tax
increases
well you'll appreciate i i can't
possibly say i mean
we have the budget on the 8th of march
uh set
and uh the chancellor and the treasury
team will be working very very hard and
of course
uh taking into account these figures but
the package of support that we've rolled
out over the last year
uh comes to some 280 billion pounds
it has helped protect some 12 million
jobs and
many millions of businesses so we want
to be there to help businesses survive
this very difficult period
so that when we're through the pandemic
we can continue with
our agenda on leveling up for the entire
country
are you at least able to say whether the
furlough scheme might be extended that's
something people are very very keen
to know as soon as possible well as both
prime minister
and others have indicated we have to
wait until the budget um
i i don't want to take anything away
from the chancellor
and his announcements uh in march but
what we do know is just how important
the furlough scheme
and other schemes have been over the
past year and as i say the plans that
chancellor have set down
to protect jobs and to help
businesses really have made an impact
and and although today that the news is
as it is uh we're you know we're very
we're very um
confident that the package of support
has helped
the economy okay let's move on to
something that everybody's talking about
at the minute uh their summer holiday or
the lack of have you booked yours
i completely sympathize particularly on
this very very cold
february day as i look out my window um
look we just we just can't say at the
moment
uh we have a very clear plan as to have
you know
your holiday though that was the
question i i haven't i've good as me i
haven't had time and obviously i've been
uh following very carefully the
um guidance but the prime minister has
said
next week is a critical week we're going
to gather all of the data
and review that data both international
data as to the impact of the vaccine but
also our own data
and then on the 22nd of february the
prime minister will make
a statement to the house of commons
where he'll set out our roadmap
to uh ease lockdown and and so i i can't
say anything further
uh to that but i totally get it we we're
all looking
into the summer and hoping that things
will
be better do you think that you should
just be telling people that they can
book
holidays but at their own risk allowing
them some
um discretion really rather than being
dictated to by government
well i think um at this where this
period as i say just before
uh the review next week and the prime
minister setting out the road map
i totally understand people's um wish to
start thinking about um sunnier climbs
or thinking about their holidays within
the uk
but just at this point in time we've
just got to keep tight and
and continue all that we're trying to do
to bring
the pandemic under control so all of the
measures that apply
and lock down uh our uh how long
the restrictions will last or should
last
well again we have to be led by the data
on this look we've got some fantastic
news
on the vaccination programme we are on
track to meet our target
of next monday of uh vaccinating giving
the
the first dose to the four most
vulnerable priority groups as defined by
the scientists that is great news and
quite it really is an achievement to
have got that far and then of course the
vaccine would be being rolled out
uh in accordance with the advice of jc
of the joint committee but uh until
we've got to take this step by step
and uh we're all very very keen i know
we are
to see this road map out here and as you
said
that's very positive news with that the
vaccines being rolled out so
successfully
doesn't then that point to um actually
moving out of lockdown because we have
so successfully vaccinated so many
people
well look this of course we want to move
out of lockdown
but we've got to do it uh at a safe pace
we've got to ensure
that uh we don't put at risk all of the
hard work that we've put over
put up we've been put into place uh over
january and previous months
and that's why we're conducting this
review next week after we have
uh completed the first four priority
groups with vaccination
and then the prime minister will set out
the roadmap and look you know we want to
uh for example look at schools at the
8th of march would be a daytime i
suspect parents across the country will
be watching
uh with baited breath um that is the
date that we have said look if we if we
can
if the data allows it then we're gonna
start unlocking
uh schools and so from that uh many many
things will flow but we must just wait
until the 22nd of february when the
prime minister can announce the results
of the review
and we can have a really good idea as to
what the road map looks like
sage remember sir jeremy farah says that
transmission is still incredibly high
and it doesn't make any sense to set out
a road map in february
for arbitrary dates in march or april
well we know that the our rate is going
in the right direction it's going
downwards
and of course we keep we keep this under
review it's why we're looking at the
data uh
next week where we'll have a body of
evidence both in the uk but across the
world as to the success of the
vaccination programs and what they do to
the transmission rates i'm going to
visit my local vaccination it doesn't
make any sense sorry to interrupt
running out of time he's saying it
doesn't make any sense at this point to
be setting out a road map
i mean that's quite uh an opinion that
we should be taking into account isn't
it
of course we um of course we take the
advice of the scientists very
very um seriously we also though
once the scientists medics are looking
completely understandably they're
concentrating on
the clinical and medical repercussions
of this pandemic the prime minister has
this very difficult balancing act
of keeping the public with us keeping
you know keeping us all
united in wanting to stick to the rules
to you know hands-face space and so on
and
be locked out but also has to keep an
eye on
the economy so i think it's
i think it's right actually that we
should set out a road map i think you
know people need to have some
idea as to when uh what they can expect
over the coming months
and of course part of that as you
started this interview with part of that
is looking at
the impact on the economy but also
critical services such as schools
we have to give the public uh some idea
of
of where we're going with this and
that's exactly what the prime minister
is going to do on the 26th and as you
mentioned
schools that critically need to know
they need notice as to when
to reopen is this road map going to be
set out
on the 22nd of february or the week
beginning the 22nd of february there's
been some
confusion yeah we're expecting to make
the statement on the
on monday the 22nd of february
schools will have a necessary notice
that they need about
reopening so i've been very careful
as as has been the case throughout we
have said
that we um that that decision will be
based
on the data and so this is why next week
is so important because that's the
review of the data
um but we're you know we would like to
be able to start um
announcing schools being unlocked on the
8th of march but
it is absolutely subject to the data i'm
so sorry we're in this period at the
moment
where we're just having to look at the
data i can't give you
um the sort of answers that you're
completely understandably asking for
but we've just got to take the step by
step you know when i speak to people
um you know asking constituents and so
on how they're feeling
i think most people understand that we
have got to
see out this lockdown people want us to
um for this to be the final lockdown as
the prime minister has said again and
again
so we've just got to take this step by
step and
follow the data can you tell us about
the cabinet office proposal to introduce
vaccines
um passports and testing certificates
that
the meeting that's happening today well
at this precise point in time we have no
uh plans
uh to introduce vaccine passports the
the transport secretary
has talked about the possibility of an
international system
um but we are we're a long way from that
at the moment and so
at the moment we have no plans for that
grant shaps has said talks are underway
to this effect well um he is the
transport secretary but
uh as i said we i can't i can't
speculate further at this
moment in time on that um
the public accounts committee uh fair
warning that supply problems could
threaten
reaching the targets are there issues
with
supplies of the vaccine we've been very
clear that it's
um yeah there will be uh lumpy if you
like um
uh appearance in the vaccine supply but
we we're absolutely confident that
on monday we will have met our target
of vaccinating the highest priority the
four highest priority groups
and so you know we've always said that
supply is a
is a um a factor in uh rolling out the
vaccination
but that that deadline of monday is
there
and we will meet it uh the committee
there have also said that they're
concerned about the lack of
planning after the the next stage of
people to to be vaccinated
well the the nhs have been working on
this for months i mean it's one of the
reasons why we were able
to roll the vaccine program out um as
smoothly and as quickly as we have done
and of course we have our task force of
uh
tens of thousands of volunteers as well
as doctors nurses pharmacists people
across the country helping
uh deliver these vaccines so as
time goes on inevitably the supply
system is is
becoming smoother and smoother um so i
i note those concerns but i have to say
the fact we're going to be able to meet
our target on monday i think speaks
volumes about
the success of the nhs of pulling
together this huge logistical exercise
and delivering so many vaccines to
people do you know on saturday we were
delivering on average
a thousand jabs a minute and that's an
extraordinary figure
and shows just how hard everybody in the
nhs
and in the pharmacies and all of the
centers
uh are working to help members of the
public uh get their vaccination
in good time indeed just a tiny one
quick question on the police forces in
england and wales
getting this extra 60 million pounds in
funding to help
with the enforcement of coronavirus
rules what what exactly will that be
going on
58 million pounds is going to the 43
police forces to help them with the
extra costs that they are
um and having to cover through the
pandemic
and so it will help all right all sorts
of things including
ensuring that fleet cars and stations
are covered secure
and the remaining 2 million pounds
will be specifically for police forces
who will be helping in the efforts
to police the borders in airports and
ports following
our very stringent measures that will be
happening
that are happening now but will be
further strengthened as of next week
minister thank you so much for speaking
to us this morning thank you
okay well let's get some reaction now to
that interview from our political
correspondent real pal good morning to
you
uh what did you make of what the
minister had to say good morning julian
i thought victoria atkins stuck to the
script pretty tightly not wanting to
give anything away
uh on whether that school's deadline on
the 8th of march will be meh it's about
international travel as well i thought
the one thing she said
um though uh that was um quite
interesting and could sort of plot a
path
forward or give us an indication of
where we're going forward is when she
spoke about how
they take the scientific advice
seriously but boris johnson also needs
to make sure he keeps the public on side
and needs to keep an eye on the economy
um as well so suggesting that they can't
go necessarily for the
most stringent restrictions as some
scientists might like because they need
to make sure that the public will still
stick
with them now i think that matters
because we know that the scientific
backdrop to these big decisions that are
coming in the next couple of weeks
is essentially that there will need to
be restrictions as long as not everyone
in the country is vaccinated and
potentially
even longer what victoria atkins
suggested was that the government
wouldn't necessarily be sticking
to that scientific advice to the letter
and that they would have one eye
on adherence on whether the public can
stomach any more rules and one eye on
the economy as well
okay rob for the moment thank you very
much uh let's take you back to our lead
story those
gdp figures and we've got some reaction
from the chancellor
rishi tsunak he says today's figures
show that the economy
has experienced a serious shock as a
result of the pandemic
which has been felt by countries around
the world
while there are some positive signs of
the economy's resilience over the winter
we know that the current lockdown
continues to have a significant impact
on many people and businesses that's why
my focus remains fixed on doing
everything we can to protect jobs
businesses and livelihoods at the budget
i will set out the next stage
of our plan for jobs and the support
we'll provide
through the next phase of the pandemic
that the very latest there from the
chancellor and uh we will be speaking to
him
uh later on edcom we shall be still to
come on the show
as wales announces it's met the target
to offer a vaccine to everyone in the
top four priority groups
the welsh health minister vaughan gethin
joins us at half past seven
at 25 to eight we'll be speaking to the
co-author
of a new modeling study into the uk's
vaccine rollout
which suggests the vaccine is already
bringing down covid19 deaths
at 805 i'll be getting reaction to the
latest gdp figures from
labour's shadow economic secretary to
the treasury
pat mcfadden
mental health services in the nhs are
under increasing strain
as the pandemic and ongoing lockdown
continue to put
individuals under huge strain in one
mental health trust covering southeast
london
and parts of kent psychological therapy
referrals have swollen
by 280 percent since the start of the
pandemic
doctors have also issued warnings about
the number of children
who have overdosed or self-harmed a
health correspondent ashish joshi was
given access to one trust
and has this report how long have you
stopped
your medication
two days that's not too bad the calls
keep coming this mental health crisis
line
is manned 24 hours a day seven days a
week
it needs to be and for you to look into
what
makes you feel better what makes you
feel happy we are seeing more people
contacting services who have no past
experience with mental health care
people's stresses are up
people's resources are down so the
things you might do to help with that
ordinarily may be
you go for dinner with friends you can't
do that and then the services when you
go to contact them
are really busy so we're stretched the
number of calls to their crisis lines
are 30 percent above pre-pandemic levels
i do think we're going to have a surge
in the coming months i think what's
really hard to see
is how long that's going to last and how
deeply it's going to last
we've been given rare access to the
wards of a mental health unit
and the teams of dedicated staff who
have worked
through this emergency we always run
close to full capacity and that's
something that is been the case before
the pandemic that's not been altered in
fact at the start of the pandemic
we'd push to try discharge as many
people as we could out of an anxiety
that this would be an infection hub for
them
at oxley's they've seen demand for
access to psychological therapies up by
280 percent compared to pre-pandemic
levels
it reflects what is happening across the
country
peter and this is not his real name is a
schoolboy from london
he tells me he's had some issues with
his mental health in the past
but the pandemic is making his obsessive
compulsive disorder
worse if you have a compulsion that
just simply involves door handles
but the pandemic the the problem the
issue with the pandemic is that it kind
of
gives you more time to think things
through
and because of that you start to maybe
think oh
um maybe there's something wrong with
light switches as well
and then all of a sudden it's like
you've got little things popping up here
and there
and then if you don't if you if you're
not able
to stop them in their tracks early on
early on
and they can develop further and does
that
lead to you being overwhelmed with these
thoughts
yes yeah yeah dr omar mugrabbi
is peter's consultant he told me he's
seeing a sharp
spike in cases and some
were very worrying i've seen a couple of
young people who've presented to
a e who have taken overdoses
who've cut themselves severely some
who've changed their patterns of eating
so severely that they've lost a lot of
weight that um
our colleagues medical colleagues are
treating them medically in order to save
the lives
what's driving this one can only say the
major factor across all of it is the
pandemic
it's not just the young who are affected
the elderly are particularly vulnerable
too
with some clinicians warning of a trauma
time bomb
it's the same as everything else the
longer you leave it
and the worse it's likely to get now
that's
true of cancer but it's equally true
of mental health this is exactly what dr
fadipe
is seeing in her ward she specializes in
the care
of elderly patients with dementia even
inside here
the effect of the pandemic can be felt
during the first week i think families
were a bit worried
they're presenting themselves now we've
seen an increased referrals
and we've seen the people are much worse
how worried are you about
the long-term impact isolation leading
to
low mood and depression can be a
precipitator for developing dementia
a lack of activities which we've all
seen in lockdown
can lead to or can precipitate dementia
so i am worried
that we will see repercussions of this
for years to come
successive lockdowns are taking their
mental toll on all of us
but some people will get support from
family and friends
once restrictions are lifted the real
worry
is for the people who might not be so
resilient ashish joshi sky news
south east london
and you can see a longer version of that
special report throughout the day
here on sky news
let's take a look at the latest
coronavirus figures for the uk now and
there have been
13 494 new confirmed cases of covid19
a further 678 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
it brings the uk total to 115
529 and so far
more than 13 and a half million first
doses of a vaccine
have been administered
and reminder that all the information
that's underpinned our special programs
on learning the lessons of covid this
week
is now available for you to read sky
news has compiled a detailed analysis of
every
significant moment during the pandemic
comprehensive timeline
of a year like no other and we've
published it in full on our website
for anyone and everyone to access and
explore
prosecutors in donald trump's second
impeachment trial have concluded their
arguments claiming donald trump
incited the capital riots on the 6th of
january
house prosecutors argued that american
democracy would be
tarnished for years to come if the
senate didn't convict the former
president and bar him from taking office
again
in the future over two days they
presented statements
and videos showing the extent of
violence
what is impeachable conduct if not this
i challenge you all to think about it if
you think this is not impeachable
what is what would be
if president trump's lawyers endorsed
his breathtaking assertion that his
conduct
in inciting these events was totally
appropriate
and the senate acquits donald trump than
any president
could incite and provoke insurrectionary
violence
against us again
time for a look at the weather now with
naz
and uh reminds me of when my eldest
daughter was a little toddler
it's freezing
technically below freezing for many
areas this morning
not as cold as it was yesterday morning
but we have seen temperatures drop
into minus double figures in some spots
of scotland once again
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning into the new week and we'll
start to see milder conditions that
eventually spread in from the west
but until then it's cold over the next
few days in fact
it is a chilly start again this morning
not as cold as it was yesterday morning
but still very cold for many spots
temperatures drop down into minus double
figures in some areas of scotland
and generally below freezing for most
places
there is a widespread frost out there
there's also the risk of ice across the
north and
east where there are snow showers over
northeast scotland and northeast england
and over parts of the southwest it's
windy
with the risk of ice and some rain sleet
and snow across parts of ireland and the
southwest of the uk but that will tend
to ease away
and become dry across these areas later
but the west particularly across islands
northern ireland and the southwest of
the uk stays
rather cloudy with limited amounts of
brightness and very windy with coastal
gales likely further east we'll see
drier and brighter conditions it will be
cold though and there will be the
continuation of snow showers across the
northeast too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on sky news breakfast i'll
speak to the welsh health minister
vaughan gethin
now wells has offered the vaccine to
everyone in the top
four most vulnerable groups
the nature of warfare is changing
an invisible enemy is on the rise in a
gray zone
between war and peace it's a global
battlefield
that thrives on deniability the weapons
of choice
include disinformation intimidation and
cyber attacks
everyone's a target into the gray zone
from sky news
warfare is changing and now we're all on
the front line
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
you can spread a message of positivity
with no characters at all you can just
do it with a smile
but um because many of us are
unfortunately
um separate separated because of the
situation the pandemic
um it's more appropriate than ever to um
share a message of positivity by text
so you know what many of these
sentiments were knocking around in
some of my existing poetry or things
that i say
routinely to my friends in my work when
i'm on the news
and it was just a case of distilling
these messages
and codifying them with these broad
words that we will all relate to
family work community friends hope
etc and sometimes i become flippant
about it as well i used to do this with
music too
um being hard on myself saying this
isn't a real job what is this
but you know there's a real
psychological importance to sharing
words of meaning
and messages of warmth and i credit
nokia phones for having the foresight
to involve me in this my family and
friends
you give me clarity and sense i feel you
over long distances
i learn so much from our differences
i worry about becoming a stranger i hate
knowing that you could run into danger
i think about the little ones coming of
age i think about the grown-ups
succumbing to change i'm alex crawford
and i'm sky's
special correspondent based in istanbul
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back breaking news in the last
half an hour and it's a
bad reading for the uk economy although
the economy grew
by one percent in the final quarter of
2020
in total it fell 9.9
for the year the largest annual slump
since 1709.
earlier the home office minister
victoria atkins gave her reaction to
those figures
from the office for national statistics
well we knew that the pandemic was going
to have an
impact on the economy and that's why the
measures that we took last year
to protect jobs and to safeguard
businesses have been so important if
those measures haven't
happened then i suspect we'd have looked
at we'd be looking at far worse figures
today so
you know the we we will come out of this
pandemic and the economy
will recover we've just got to keep uh
sticking with
this lockdown and we've got to stick uh
with
the plan that the chancellor has for us
moving out
of uh this period
well mps are warning that a lack of
planning could affect the next
phase of the coronavirus vaccine rollout
the next stage aims to see 17.7 million
people in the uk
aged between 50 and 70 vaccinated by the
end of
april but the commons public accounts
committee
says they were concerned that they're
concerned that there was much to be done
to reach this milestone
it comes as wales announced it's hit its
own target to offer the vaccine to
everyone
in the top four priority groups by
mid-february
i'm joined now by the welsh health
minister vaughan gethin
good morning to you did you expect
to meet this target uh are you surprised
that you've realized the target that was
set
no i'm not surprised i'm tremendously
grateful for all the amazing work that
our nhs led program has delivered here
in wales as partners in local government
volunteers
and some military support too we were
always confident despite a slightly
slower start in the first few weeks than
other parts of the uk that we were able
to catch up and remove very very quickly
once we had both the fisa vaccine and
the astrozenica vaccine available
we could bring essentially general
practice and other local healthcare
operators on board with our mass
vaccination centers so
it's been a tremendous job of work and a
real achievement it should give everyone
i think confidence
that we will reach them too in the next
day to get to the next five priority
groups
and then the wider adult population
through the summer and into the autumn
what about those that have missed
appointments or uh
refusing actually to to take the
vaccination
how will that be approached well we're
operating a leave no one behind
approach that means that if you've
missed your appointment then you can
still
rebook we know that some people would
have been ill and would be able to have
attended
some people will change their mind and
the offer of the vaccine isn't a
once-in-a-lifetime offer
if you're saying no and you change your
mind we hope people will do because
there are some groups
that are more hesitant about taking the
vaccine then you can do that and the nhs
won't leave you behind
so i think that's really important for
the 92 percent of people
who already had the vaccine in the first
four groups that's good news
for those who yet to have it that's good
news and if you're in that about eight
percent today that have yet to have it
in those first four groups
don't worry because the nhs won't forget
you won't leave me behind
and you can still change your mind but
for those who do refuse that there's
nothing you can do is there
no indeed and you know vaccination is
not compulsory
it is an offer to help protect people
for themselves their family their
community and other people they may
never get to meet we know that without
significant
protection from the wider population
then we will have to live with
extraordinary measures long into the
future
vaccination is a key part of allowing us
to recover a more normal way of living
our lives and i for one will be ready
and willing to have my vaccine when my
turn comes
and i think that's really important that
the confidence we all have in the safety
and effectiveness of the vaccines
as well of course is paying tribute to
the fantastic work that our nhs has done
here in wales
because the the vaccination program has
gone so well will you be looking to
relax restrictions to ease lockdown
well we still have a balance of things
to consider vaccination is part of what
we'll think about in terms of the future
but it's also really about the
suppression of virus transmission
you'll recall we had extraordinary rates
of coronavis transmission across wales
just before christmas
rates across wales of over 650 and a
hundred thousand they're now
uh not far above a hundred half of our
local authorities in wales have rates of
below one hundred per hundred thousand
so significant progress but still
relatively high
to allow lots and lots of areas of
activity to open our
schools should be reopening the
face-to-face learning from the 22nd
of february for our youngest children up
the age of seven
that's a really important step forward
not just for those children their
families
but i think more broadly for all of us
to regain some confidence in our ability
to start reopening
other areas of life while not seeing the
virus take off there are still
lots of people vulnerable to harm that's
why we need to carry on with the
quickest place possible
with our vaccination program and all of
us need to stick with it
we have a shorter road ahead of us but
the road ahead is in terms of months
stick with it and we can all recover
together much more of our normal lives
you said that over the next couple of
weeks you're expecting a slight
reduction
in the the quantity of vaccines from
received from the the uk government
and what what planning have you put in
place to prevent that being an issue
well we're having to manage then the
range of areas that we're delivering our
vaccine from
so that means we're going to see some
reduced levels of delivery
we're also of course having to manage
the reality we're starting to do more
and more second doses as well
so the way in which we use a fiber
vaccine has to balance both the second
doses that are required
as well as getting to more people in
first doses and as we showed earlier
in the vaccination program if we do have
a
quieter period of a couple of weeks we
can then pick up
very quickly when we expect to have
significantly increased volumes through
march as well
we then expect to bring on board more of
our colleagues in community pharmacy to
help deliver a significant chunk of the
program too
so we're ready planning for not just the
next two weeks but the weeks have come
after that and again
much bigger volumes of delivery that you
can expect here in wales
well getting thank you very much for
speaking to us this morning
thank you
now a new study says the uk's
vaccination program is already reducing
the number of daily deaths but it says
as the rollout continues
it may be the time to target high-risk
key workers
rather than simply going downwards
through the age groups
the study is in the journal of the
association of anesthetists
and the co-author dr tim cook is a
consultant
anesthesia and intensive care medicine
uh he works there and joins uh
me now good morning to you uh i know
that you've just um
come off shift uh you've done a an
overnight shift and you can't speak
about the specifics
at your hospital but how was it through
the night for you
uh it's um sorry i tried to find a quiet
place around the hospital
this may not be the quiet place um
uh busy um got a couple of hours sleep
intensive cares across the country are
extremely busy and will remain so for
some time to come
and what are the the pressures that that
icus are working under
well we have about the equivalent of
an extra 150 intensive cares open
compared to our normal
so the normal in the uk is that we have
about 200 intensive cares
and the degree of expansion that has
happened
um to cope with this second surge is the
equivalent of
opening approximately somewhere between
another 150
and 200 intensive cares so although
not all those intensive cares are full
there are effectively twice as many beds
staffed by the same number of full-time
intensive care nurses and doctors
supported by many other clinicians
and as i say this is not going to turn
around very quickly
what have you found through your study
so it's a modeling study so like all
models it makes
assumptions we hope the assumptions are
valid
and we hope that the findings are useful
what we found is that
as is already known that the vaccines
will have a reasonably
rapid impact on mortality so that we
will see
uh deaths uh from from kovid falling
we're probably seeing it already so at
the moment we're seeing a combination of
a reduction in deaths uh from uh
both from lockdown but also from the
impact of vaccines
which takes about five weeks to come
through
but because the patients who are in
hospital are about 10 years younger on
average than patients who die
and the patients in intensive care are
another 10 or 12 years younger than
the average patient admitted to hospital
um the impact on
on on admissions to both those places is
delayed
and so probably it will take another
month or five weeks
for the impact of the vaccination
to have a significant impact on on those
measures so what i mean by that is that
while
uh mortality if everything goes very
well there's a best case scenario
mortality from covet will reduce
by more than 80 percent by the end of
march
um it will take at least another month
for us to see the impact on hospital
admissions and iq admissions
which emphasizes the importance of
ongoing vaccination and really
vaccinating quite deep into the
population
so you're talking about the the one to
four that that first uh
cohort being vaccinated if you then add
on the the other levels five to seven
then what does that do to the figure
yeah so one to four is patients over 70
um and uh frontline healthcare and
social care workers
which we're approaching this week
and that that reduces mortality
by almost eighty percent when the
effects are
seen as i said which will be in several
weeks but it only reduces
itu emissions by about 30 percent and
it's going to take
uh as you say vaccinating into
along to group seven which is all
patients over 60
and the extremely extremely clinically
vulnerable and high risk
to reduce hospital admissions and
mortality
hospital ambitions and itu uh
down to figures are around beyond sixty
percent
um what are the schools of thought of
how to proceed
after the one to seven category after
that's been
been achieved what what's the road map
from there on in
so it's extraordinarily noisy here um
the options are not mine of course
um what our modeling shows the ones is
that once you've fascinated
more than 50 of the adult population
then the impact
um on deaths possible admissions and it
missions
tends to flatten off and at that point
there is perhaps a decision to be made
should the vaccination program
reconsider should it focus on younger
people to reduce transmission on key
workers
or perhaps even there's the global
perspective should some of the uk
vaccine
be redirected to countries who have less
access as
global vaccination is is an essential
part
of what we do and it's in our
self-interest to ensure that vaccines
reach
countries beyond our shores tim cook
thanks for finding the quietest wall
that you you could
go off and have some sleep now thank you
my pleasure still to come
on sky news breakfast as senior
democrats close their case against
donald trump
in his historic second impeachment trial
we'll take a closer look at whether
he'll
actually be convicted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
phillip no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
[Music]
now it's been compelling viewing
watching the impeachment trial against
donald trump
seeing again the shocking scenes as his
supporters burst into the capital the
seat of the u.s congress
but it's even more likely that uh mr
trump will
be impeached joining me now is
bernadette meyer professor of law
at stanford and an expert in american
constitutional law
uh welcome to you um as i was saying
there those pictures
released for the first time quite
shocking
will they have any bearing on the
impeachment trial though
i think that senators across the aisle
have been impressed by the images
republicans have acknowledged
being moved by the democrats case but
i think not enough to ensure conviction
of donald trump there are a couple
obstacles i think standing in the way of
republicans
going all the way uh in favor of
impeachment
how strong is the argument that donald
trump actually
incited violence
i think from a criminal perspective
incitement is an extremely high bar uh
because
the us is kind of exceptional in how it
treats free speech
under the first amendment there's a
requirement for
criminal prosecutions that incitement
really
be intended to produce an immediate and
uh violent effect now i i think that
what trump did
meets that bar but it doesn't need to
meet that bar
for impeachment proceedings because
impeachment proceedings have always
had a different standard than criminal
trials the senate
is the sole body in power to try
impeachments
and that means that they really get to
decide what the standards are
procedurally and substantively
at the same time i think a lot of
senators are going to say oh we're not
really convinced
that trump actually caused
this violence you know he may have
condoned it but he wasn't
trying to get the rioters to
storm the capital and invade the senate
proceedings
what the democrats are trying to show is
a pattern
of behavior on donald trump's part and
the fact that he showed
no remorse and then appealing for a
bipartisan
approach but you don't think that that's
going to happen you think that will fall
on deaf ears
i think that that will fall on deaf ears
and that
other senators will decide that because
he's no longer president
that uh there's not really a
constitutional power
to impeach him uh yeah
if he isn't impeached um what bearing
does that have on
whether he'll be able to run for public
office again
that's a separate process isn't it
exactly so the problem
i think that democrats see is that if
he's not impeached
that will mean that he can still be
eligible to run for public office if he
were
impeached then they could just take a
majority vote to disqualify him from
future
public office um without the impeachment
conviction
that's going to be a lot more difficult
now there is another possibility
that democrats could contemplate and
that comes from the 14th amendment of
the constitution which was
uh ratified after the u.s civil war
and was intended in part to bar people
who had fought for the confederacy
from holding future office so section 3
of the 14th amendment says that
anyone who is involved in insurrection
against the united states or who gives
comfort to the enemies of the united
states
is barred from federal office so that
could be decided by a vote of congress
and that's another potential way that
trump could be barred from office the
consensus
is that that he will be acquitted do you
agree with that
i don't think so i i think he should be
convicted uh
but i also thought he should be
convicted the first time around um
and i i just think that the bar for
impeachment is so high
that you have to have a two-thirds vote
of the senate there's almost nothing
that two-thirds
of senators uh will agree on so
you know i think i think it's just
implausible politically that it would
happen
but i don't agree with the outcome thank
you so much for sharing your expertise
with us this morning
bernadette mila thank you
now chancellor rishi sunak has been
giving his reaction to the latest gdp
figures which came out
a few moments ago
in today's figure show that last year
our economy experienced a significant
shock and while there were some signs of
resilience
over winter you know what's clear is
right now many families
and businesses are experiencing hardship
that's why we've put in place a
comprehensive plan for jobs to support
people through this crisis
and we will set out the next stage of
our economic response
at our budget in early march
and we'll be hearing from more from the
chancellor in the next hour time now for
the weather though naz
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it is going to be cold for
the next few days but into the new week
we'll eventually start to see
milder conditions but until then yes
cold chilly this morning in fact again
it is
very cold with temperatures below
freezing overnight for most places
into minus double figures across parts
of scotland but not as low as they were
yesterday so it's a less cold morning
frosty
there is a risk of ice as well across
the northeast where there are some snow
showers there and over southwestern
areas it's
windy there's some patchy outbreaks rain
sleet and snow across parts of ireland
in the southwest of the uk
and there is also the risk of ice there
too now through the day
we will see that to rain sleet and snow
tend to ease so i think it will become
dry across these parts but it will stay
quite cloudy for
parts of the west windy as well with
coastal girls likely not as windy
further east
but it's going to be mainly dry and
bright but with snow showers in the
northeast
the weather sponsored by qatar airways